[Musique]
l'incontrôlable comptables aux
etats-unis le 4 vivent hors de voilà
tous les invités intérieur à skype
maintenant par mesure de précaution et
la plupart des chroniqueurs aussi
impérial de leur maison
[Musique]
important
toute la difficulté aujourd'hui bien et
continue à pouvoir informer notre public
tout en évidemment protégeant du salarié
protégé nos salariés ça veut dire moins
de personnes sur le site ici à france 24
[Musique]
or
abandonne ses buts
tous
on est trois quatre maximum en
respectant les distances bien sûr mais
en fait ce qu'on fait ici c'est quoi
tous les reporter on leur matériel leur
matériel de tournage et de montage chez
eux
et puis bah on les envoie il parte sur
les reportages et nous les envoient et
il ne met pas des pierres enceinte cap
[Musique]
c'est devenu beaucoup plus compliqué de
calais de reportage beaucoup
d'intervenants uns préfèrent nous
accorder des entretiens mais à distance
[Musique]